[Music]
hey Wolfgang so today I stumbled across
a leak that talks about the plot of
spider-man homecoming - there's a lot of
great info in this leak including talk
about Mysterio being hired by a major
villain to steal some groundbreaking
technology from Tony Stark villian
hasn't been specified yet but it said
that the villain is going to have a
prominent role in the upcoming movies
and it's going to be played by an a-list
actor so there's a lot of excitement
coming with spider-man homecoming -
there's a lot in this leak that's really
great about spider-man homecoming - but
I actually don't want to talk about
spider-man in this video I want to talk
about what does leaked reveals to us
about a major character death in
Avengers 4 if this leak ends up being
true then obviously this is going to be
a major spoiler for Avengers 4 so watch
at your own risk and I must add that
this source does have some credibility
to it this source leaked some details
about Avengers infinity war that ended
up being true so again watch at your own
risk
so to start off Peter is obviously alive
which means that in Avengers Ford they
somehow figure out a way to reverse
stano's to snap this shouldn't come as a
huge surprise to most people because I
think it's fairly obvious that in
Avengers Ford they're going to figure
out a way to reverse the snap somehow
but that does not mean that some major
characters will not permanently die
keypoint the plot of this states that in
the beginning of the movie Peter will be
mourning the death of Tony Stark that's
right this states that iron man will die
in Avengers 4 this could very well
happen as Robert Downey jr. is one of
the actors that has not renewed his
contract and as far as we know Avengers
4 will in fact be his last movie in the
MCU and it's been stated that there are
going to be some major deaths in
Avengers infinity war and there weren't
any so that leads many of us to believe
that there will be some major deaths in
Avengers 4 the Russo brothers themselves
have practically confirmed this in an
interview when asked
about character deaths they compared new
actors to a new blossoming flower and
the old actors to fully blossom flowers
they stated that they didn't want to cut
off a flower as it was beginning to grow
and blossom but a fully blossomed flower
yes if it fits with the plot so it
doesn't look like things are looking too
bright for Iron Man but if he does in
fact go I think this leek actually tells
us a little bit more about the role
he'll play in Avengers for the leek
states that misty really be the main
villain and that he has stolen some sort
of groundbreaking technology from Stark
Industries I think this will probably be
some sort of time travel technology that
Tony Stark creates as I've stated before
Avengers 4 is pretty much confirmed to
be a time travel movie they're going to
have to somehow go back in time to undo
fanless snap or as it's been rumored to
create their own Infinity Gauntlet it's
also been rumored that somehow Tony will
create his own version of the Infinity
stones which is kind of comforting to
know if he is in fact going to die in
Avengers 4 I think we all thought he was
gonna die at the end of infinity war I
certainly thought he was gonna die when
Thanos stabbed him but he didn't and
maybe that was the Russo brothers
preparing us all for him actually dying
in Avengers 4 if you ask me I think he's
going to die one way or another I think
this is the end for Tony Stark but what
do you guys think do you think that
they're actually going to kill him off
and he's dunzo or do you think that
they'll just retire Tony Stark and the
mantle will be passed on to somebody
else let me know down there in the
comment section and if you enjoyed this
video please hit that thumbs up button
and be sure to subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date on Avengers for
spider-man homecoming to all things
Marvel DC and superhero thank you so
much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]